[Musica]
mi occupo di acqua dal 2008 dal giorno
in cui mia sorella mi regala un libro
bellissimo e che mi cambia la vita
le guerre dell'acqua di vandana shiva
oggi sono qui per parlarvi della
relazione tra acqua e cibo una relazione
complessa problematica troppo spesso
sottovalutata ma prima di fare questo
devo fare un passo indietro dal 1950
siamo entrati nell'antro pace né l'era
geologica caratterizzata dalla
trasformazione dall'intervento massiccio
dell'uomo sul pianeta che lo sta
alterando a livello territoriale
atmosferico e idrologico profondamente
alcuni dei cambiamenti in atto nel
antropocene sono irreversibili prima tra
tutti il cambiamento climatico che non è
soltanto un fenomeno ambientale ma che
ha implicazioni molto forti sociali
politiche economiche il cambiamento
climatico è stato collegato infatti all
insorgere di conflitti alle migrazioni
di intere popolazioni
e anche a fenomeni come quello delle
acquisizioni di terra su larga scala
un fenomeno che quando avviene in
negazione del diritto umano prende il
nome di land grabbing cioè di
accaparramento di terra il pianeta è
letteralmente ricoperto di acqua ma solo
lo 0,001 per cento di quest'acqua che
ricopre il pianeta è disponibile per
l'uso umano
il resto infatti acqua salata oppure si
trova allo stato solido o non è
direttamente accessibile l'acqua inoltre
distribuita nel panetta in maniera
estremamente diseguale
troviamo infatti che quasi il 70 per
cento delle riserve di acqua dolce sono
concentrati e soltanto in 13 paesi del
mondo i problemi idrici hanno radici
diverse da una parte troviamo un tipo di
scarsità che alla sua radice nella
mancanza di acqua in un territorio
questo tipo di scarsità colpisce una
persona su cinque sul pianeta e appunto
si verifica quando la quantità di acqua
in un'area non riesce a soddisfare i
bisogni della popolazione che la abitano
generalmente questo tipo di scarsità si
trova in paesi che sono largamente
dipendenti dalle importazioni di cibo e
tra poco scopriremo perché c'è un altro
tipo di scarsità un tipo di scarsità
molto più preoccupante della precedente
perché avviene in contesti di povertà e
che colpisce una persona su quattro sul
pianeta
questo tipo di scarsità e radicata nelle
condizioni sociali economiche e
istituzionali che precludono l'accesso
all'acqua parte della popolazione perché
è preoccupante perché non avere accesso
all'acqua il diritto all'acqua negato un
diritto quello che dovrebbe essere che è
un diritto umano significa non poter
uscire dalla trappola della povertà
per questo deve preoccuparci ancora di
più l'agricoltura è il cuore del
problema
l'elefante nella stanza questo perché il
70 per cento dell'acqua dolce che
preleviamo è appunto dedicata alla
produzione di cibo e di beni agricoli in
generale questa percentuale sale molto
in paesi aridi o semi aridi fino ad
arrivare ad oltre il 90 per cento
l'agricoltura è inoltre un settore
importante anche dal punto di vista
dell'impatto delle emissioni è infatti
il secondo settore che mette più
gas serra nell'atmosfera quindi è
proprio qui che dobbiamo andare ad
analizzare e capire il problema ma
poiché l'agricoltura ci nutre e qui che
dobbiamo anche andare a cercare le
soluzioni
negli ultimi 100 anni la popolazione è
cresciuta in modo esponenziale ma ancora
di più è cresciuto il consumo di acqua
ad un tasso che è pari a più del doppio
di quello della crescita della
popolazione
questo perché abbiamo modificato
profondamente il modo in cui viviamo in
particolare abbiamo modificato il nostro
consumo di cibo e al modificare le
nostre abitudini alimentari la nostra
dieta abbiamo allargato la nostra
impronta idrica pro capite a livello
individuale abbiamo bisogno infatti di
circa 2 litri per dissetarci di acqua
tra i 30 ei 50 per l'uso domestico ma
ogni giorno ognuno di noi ha bisogno di
almeno 2.000 litri di acqua per mangiare
questo perché l'acqua è un input di
produzione è fondamentale nella
produzione di cibo in tutte le fasi
della filiera in particolare nella prima
la fase sul campo la coltivazione e
questa l'intuizione che ha avuto toni al
professore del king's college e il mio
supervisor di dottorato nel chiamare
questa acqua acqua virtuale perché
un'acqua non più visibile all'interno
del cibo ma che effettivamente è stata
utilizzata per produrlo a tipi di
alimenti diversi corrispondono impronte
idriche diverse abbiamo bisogno infatti
di circa un metro cubo di acqua per
produrre 1.000 calorie vegetali ma
abbiamo bisogno di cinque metri cubi di
acqua per produrre 1.000 calorie animali
però fermarci a guardare l'ampiezza
dell'impronta idrica non è abbastanza
perché ciò che determina la
sostenibilità di un prodotto non è
soltanto il volume di acqua contenuto in
modo virtuale al suo interno ma è il
rispetto della vocazione di un
territorio
il rispetto
delle pratiche agricole sostenibili il
contesto in cui è avvenuto e questo che
va a determinare la sostenibilità o meno
del prodotto che portiamo sulle nostre
tavole
quello che vedete era il lago di aral un
lago tra kazakistan uzbekistan che negli
ultimi trent'anni abbiamo quasi
interamente prosciugato per produrre il
riso e cotone destinato all'export
questo lago ha raddoppiato la sua
concentrazione salina
negli ultimi 30 anni è diminuito il
volume delle sue a che di qui circa 15
metri
il commercio il commercio agricolo il
commercio di cibo in particolare
stabilisce una relazione una relazione
tra me che mangio è il paese in cui la
produzione agricola ha avuto luogo
questo commercio questo legame
invisibile mi rende anche vulnerabili a
crisi libri che che possono colpire i
paesi apparentemente lontani ma che
possono ad andare influenzare il mio
approvvigionamento di cibo quindi la mia
capacità di mangiare determinati tipi di
alimenti ad esempio in europa il 40 per
cento della nostra impronta idrica
alimentare proviene da paesi
extraeuropei e alcuni di questi sono
paesi estremamente vulnerabili dal punto
di vista idrico mettendo a repentaglio
intere filiere ad esempio quella del
riso del cotone o della soia di fronte a
questo scenario come si prospetta il
futuro
la risposta che mi sono dato è questa se
noi non cambiamo le cose non cambieranno
anzi peggioreranno perché tra 30 anni
saremo in 10 miliardi su questo pianeta
otto persone su dieci vivranno in città
vivere in città significa distaccarsi
progressivamente dal cibo vivere una
sorta di alienazione da chi l'ha
prodotto da come è stato prodotto dalla
stagionalità dalla vocazione di un
territorio perché abbiamo a disposizione
tutto in qualsiasi momento dell'anno
ed è proprio allora da qui che dobbiamo
ripartire
io credo per costruire un futuro diverso
prima di tutto è importante ripensare
l'agricoltura
l'agricoltura del futuro deve produrre
meglio quindi con più efficienza e con
meno con meno risorse e importante dal
punto di vista politico dare gli
strumenti investire negli agricoltori
nella loro formazione nel dare accesso
alle tecnologie perché effettivamente
possano aiutarci a transitare verso
modalità di produzione più sostenibili
in particolare i piccoli agricoltori da
cui dipende la nostra sicurezza
alimentare i politici hanno anche un
altro grande dovere quello di smettere
di sussidiare produzioni agricole che
sono dannose per l'ambiente e che spesso
non vanno neanche nella direzione degli
obiettivi di salute pubblica e noi siamo
quello che mangiamo
quindi è importante che loro prendono
questo impegno a chi fa ricerca
l'impegno non soltanto di continuare a
lavorare per migliorare la conoscenza ma
anche di favorire la comprensione
cercando di non aver paura di occasioni
belle ed emozionanti come quella di oggi
favorendo quindi la comprensione delle
persone delle persone che come cittadini
e come consumatori i consumatori di cibo
hanno un grandissimo potere il potere di
influenzare chi il cibo lo produce
chiedendo tracciabilità chiedendo
trasparenza chiedendo responsabilità
sociale e ambientale
prima di lasciarvi voglio dirvi
un'ultima cosa c'è una una teoria che
ipotizza che tra due persone in
qualsiasi punto del pianeta esista una
catena di non più di sei intermediari
quello che vi chiedo è di condividere le
idee che avete ascoltato oggi e di
chiedere la vostra rete di fare
altrettanto perché in questo modo mi
avete aiutato a trasformare la
conoscenza in consapevolezza che credo
sia all arma di costruzione di massa o
più potente che abbiamo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]